e aí
como fazer para abrir para mim tá aqui
no sedex floripa eu sou o espectador
ácido do tribeca nos pede talco na
verdade né na internet eu sou professor
de inglês e educador musical a eu sou
nascido em porto alegre e vim para cá
muito pequena ele sempre teve contato
com a música e sempre você ir da da
linguagem enquanto essa ponte aí para
gente trocar não só palavras o
pensamento aí sentimentos e isso que
estamos aguiar a nossa nossas relações
interpessoais mas também tem uma questão
que a gente consegue se comunicar além
das palavras né então seja produção
sonora seja um choro seja um olhar e uma
necessidade que a gente esprime
simplesmente contar perto vibrando um do
outro em algumas experiências na áfrica
eu consegui resgatar essas lentes
qualidade para tentar entender essa
nossa brasilidade que é uma mistura de
um pouco de tudo né aliás muito
olá eu sou muito grato por ter nascido
no brasil nessa época principalmente que
a gente tá avacalhando mesmo né são
lutas e batalhas na que a gente acha o
nosso lugar enquanto é a nossa fala aí a
gente tem que lembrar que a gente as
pessoas não nos dão a voz mas o que tem
a voz já a gente tem que se reverbera
juntos reverberar um outro e achar essa
fala na empatia de um outro é muito
importante esse esse momento aqui na
prodexor isso aí eu estou muito honrado
de estar aqui hoje fazendo música e
falando sobre o som hoje eu vou falar
uma coisa antes agora que mais tarde eu
vou resgatar o o ser humano né no
segundo todas as pesquisas neurocin
típicas é muito mais visual a gente usa
mais muito mais o sentido da visão do
que o último na maioria dos casos na
maioria das culturas e etnias mas uma
coisa que
e o vídeo não tem pálpebra então não
adianta fechar a gente fechar o olho
senão vai ver nós vai imaginar a gente
tá sempre escutando alguma coisa na
minha área da música gente trata com
isso dessa forma é assim como todas as
outras vibrações aí não param nunca de
manar eu vou fazer uma música agora e
acima de tudo os usos estão as vezes as
milhares de anos atrás são contadores de
história né seja a mãe contando uma
história embalando a gente quando a
criança para dormir e já aquele contador
de histórias viajante um os tempos
remotos financiam o
a picape não passar não vai levar a de
goiabeira na beira do rio para o para me
conhecer mas água sair um pouquinho
vezes eu ligo minuto perguntaram no
parar de fazer ele está localizada de
goiabeira na beira do rio para o
paralímpicos perder mas nós aí um
pouquinho desse seu livrinho eu tenho um
carinho para lhe fazer sim eu uso paraná
que bom o mariano malta
a bomba do pará pitombeira aborto maria
imagem meu ativar já pediu mais minuto
eu fiz mas não é deus mais acham que
levou amor nunca esposa seu cachorro
[Música]
seja a capital conseguiu visualizar aqui
foi a primeira na vila do frio para o
para mim poder vem da água saiu um
pouquinho desse seu like se eu tentar
parar de fazer gênesis capítulo vai
levar de goiabeira na beira do rio para
o parabéns mãe d'água sair um pouquinho
desse seu livro minuto tem um carinho
para lhe fazer assim
e o paraná que bom o maria do mar uma do
pará pitombeira nabor i will surely die
olá eu sou seu filho já não é mais fácil
sim levou o amor tranquilo meu capim isa
meu caramba param sofá para mim
[Música]
a dama
e o agente muito congresso amigo do
simpósio muitos encontros sobre a
educação musical eu faço licenciatura em
música é um pouco diferente do
bacharelado e mais destinado ao estudo
de um instrumento são umas arado ele se
até aula de fisiologia né usar os dois
instrumentos na licenciatura
a sala de poesia e outras coisas que
envolve o estudo da cabeça mesmo da
psique não igual certo principalmente né
oi e a gente tenta desmistificar a
questão do dou é porque assim essa
questão do bom tá muito ligada às
religiões que na época não sei mas são
assim né somente acidental ou estou
ligado é uma questão de bobeira mesmo né
aquele cara temos um aquela outra etnia
não tem um bom porque tem uma ventrículo
mas demoníaca pires ou então boas por
exemplo a gente tá aqui a gente tem que
falar intolerância religiosa porque a
gente não vai ser que a gente vai
resolver as coisas lá na faculdade a
gente tenta desmistificar por isso que
uma criança de falar eu não tenho eu que
a gente mais escuta dando aula de inglês
e dando aula de música eu tô falando que
meu lugar de fala não pede tem outro
estado também então aquela criança que
vão se ver representada tocando piano de
gravata né porque não como assim vai ter
um outro cara comigo
o público também logo logo no google ou
seja não tem outro motivo que ela não
começou o conhecimento sujeito em inglês
ele é um baita desafio para mim ele é
agora nós vamos falar agora tu vai tocar
violão agora vocês vão fazer pentatonico
fizeram lindamente então é
não pode bater palma o código para
crianças mim ou respirar no centro
respirar no tempo de alguma coisa você
legal aí se balançar tá vou fazer uma
música então é uma história não ri que
não tinha castelo em coroa mas todo
lugar que ele ia as pessoas sabiam da
verdade dele
e provavelmente e as certamente por
causa da magia do invisível essas coisas
a gente não precisa falar não consigo
escrever a gente não precisa não escutar
pode tá perto as vezes longe mais um
vibração em contato a gente já sente
isso é tudo intenção né ele lá na rua os
livros sagrados estava escrito no
princípio era o verbo o verbo não era
aqui ser uma intenção é incrível muito
antes da bíblia né ou três mil anos oito
mil anos depois resistências dizendo
isso já é nóis essa história desse jeito
não são castelo nem coroa e
e aí
o liverpool para por favor ação deve-se
limpar isso aqui na rua padre luiz rech
visualizar to youtube pai mundo é
o youtube vai acabou se não é
e aí ele disse em levar comendo luís
[Música]
eduardo a
a ligação com ai dele tudinho xuxa
really like your of moving on
e aí levi o
[Música]
te pegar
o que bem emocionado as pessoas sempre
tem problema isso faz parte também a
gente está errado se levantar e você
está fazendo ele tava junto tem que tava
ficando aqui de sozinha eu vou mais
rápido mas nunca a gente vai bem mais
longe eu sou muito grato por aqui muito
obrigado
[Música]